Hi and welcome back to
the Neil Ashton podcast.
Today I wanted to talk about a topic
that is probably on many people's
minds. This is the topic
of how will AI affect my
career? How much does it affect
the choice that you may be making?
If you're an undergraduate or
postgraduate wondering how is this gonna
affect my job prospects,
what career should I go in?
If you're in a sector that you believe
is potentially gonna change because of
AI, should you retrain?
I believe there is tremendous
positivity and promise with AI,
but I am also sensitive to the
fact that it can cause anxiety and
uncertainty, particularly for younger
people who are early on in their careers.
And I wanted to at least give my
opinion and it's just an opinion
and it's based on limited knowledge that
I have and could be completely wrong.
But I wanted to go through and also
really focus probably a little bit
more on people who are earlier on in
their careers and the things that
I think are good to focus on.
The idea is really: should you still be,
you know, specializing in engineering
or sciences or maths in the era of AI.
So, why ask this now? Well, you
know, it's clear to see that AI
is getting better and better
and by AI in some sense,
I mean, large language models.
So their ability to write code and
analyze data is just tremendous.
I struggle to find anybody
nowadays who isn't using some
sort of coding agent to develop code.
More and more, I speak to friends
of mine who are not at all
in the technology industry.
And they are, you know, really
on board and love the desktop
and mobile applications, you know,
whether it's Gemini or ChatGPT or any
others. And so it really is
now, I think today in August of
2026, gone past any sense
of, this is just hype.
You know, I think people are seeing
genuine usefulness out of AI.
But if you look at those various
reports from like the World Economic
Forum, I picked out some stat here,
around 39% of workers' skills will
change by 2030. And so the
question is really how to
prepare for that change.
Now, when it comes to
engineering, and maths and
sciences, I cannot see
a short or medium term,
and longer term it's science
fiction to think about longer term.
But in the short to medium
term, as in years and decades,
there's only an increased
need for engineers.
If we look across energy,
for nuclear, for wind,
even still for fossil fuels, there
is a huge need to build that
out. Of course, for AI, there's
a massive focus on energy.
There's still a lot of amazing
research going on on nuclear
fusion. And that sector needs people.
Transport, buildings,
electronics, manufacturing.
There's a buzz now in the
semiconductor industry.
There's a huge focus in defence,
whether we like it or not.
And there's a shortage of engineers.
Anybody who speaks to a company will
know that it's difficult to hire,
it's difficult to find good people.
Now that may sound odd to graduates
who are struggling to find a job,
but there is still a need for it.
And it is hard to predict what tasks will
change, but I would say
routine coding, you know,
simulation setup, writing
documentation, that sort of thing is
going to become much more of an AI-driven
thing. That doesn't mean that
we're hiring less developers,
but it does mean that the skills
that you need are changing.
And in some ways I see
this as a positive thing.
And I think I've told this story
before, but Like many other people
who did a more classical engineering
degree, I was not a hardcore programmer
where when I did it, 20 years
ago whenever it was, we didn't
do as much on programming,
we didn't do as much on that,
it was more about engineering.
And probably 10 years ago or five years ago,
I did sometimes feel that that
held me back a little bit when I
wanted to, you know, test
an idea out, write a code,
do some more sophisticated analysis.
I kind of realized I couldn't do that.
And I actually felt that was a limitation.
And I kept saying to myself,
I should really go and,
you know, do some immersive
course in Python or,
you know, do something to really
become amazing at programming as if
that would help me. Or, for things
that I've mentioned before like,
computer-aided design (CAD), I always said,
if someone today said,
Neil, design a, you know,
front wing of a Formula One
car, I would conceptually,
well, more than conceptually, I
would know what I need to do,
but I just don't have the
ability to do it in CATIA or NX
or whatever CAD package.
And so again, I would
probably therefore think,
well, I can't do it because
I don't have those skills.
So now with AI, I know
that I can code pretty
much anything up. Now I'm not
talking about building an
enterprise-quality thing and we
can get to that in a minute,
which still requires people with the
skills of how to create a good program,
how to organize, how to have a
team of people working on it.
But just in terms of developing
prototypes or just automating
things in a typical engineering company.
When I was in Formula One, I was
doing a lot of the methodology.
I think those teams exist
basically in every company,
which is, you know, you have a bunch of
designers or aerodynamicists and this
is across all of CAE now.
But you had a core group of people who
would actually decide what methods
would be used. How would you script it?
How would you automate it? How would
you make it the most efficient?
And that's what I was working on.
And a lot of what we were doing was
scripting and automating things.
Now, I would imagine if you
go into a Formula One team,
it would be totally transformative
compared to when I was there
in terms of there's no barrier to
the sophistication because you have
probably the world's best coding
agent in some of these AI tools now.
So why am I saying this?
I'm saying that in some ways AI is
a great enabler and democratizes
knowledge. It is a level setter.
It actually in some ways makes
more people able to do the jobs
that they couldn't do before.
I strongly believe that.
I think AI can help you;
you could apply for a job and
AI could help you to do that
job. So in that sense, rather
than it being a negative thing,
I would say I would now feel more
comfortable going into a job that
I wouldn't probably have applied for
before because I know AI is gonna be
there to help me. So that is
a positive thing in my mind.
Now, if you think about it,
what really matters are
still the fundamentals.
So another example I give is
if someone said to me now,
go and work in a bio company
looking at drug discovery.
I haven't got a biology degree.
I have no idea how drug discovery works.
I have no chemistry background,
no biology background,
no medical background. For
sure, I could, you know,
get a really good AI model.
And I'm sure it could do many of
the things that someone would ask
me to do. But I would have
no idea if it was right or
not. I could be smart and I could
maybe get a couple of different
models and get the model
to check the other model.
But I really would be just,
you know, a dumb user of it.
I really wouldn't have any sense.
I have no background in that.
So in that way, until AI
models become so unbelievably
good. And that, I think in a broad
sense, will still take a long
time. There will always need
to be the people there to
orchestrate and guide and check and sort of,
yeah, orchestrate is the word I like to use.
So in that sense, does the fact
that AI is great at drug discovery
mean that you shouldn't study biology
and chemistry and go into that?
No, of course you need to, you
need people with that background.
If we go to engineering, the
reason that I find AI so useful to
me is I have an engineering degree
and a good knowledge of the area.
So if I ask the AI to help me to do a task,
I'm able to steer it to point
it and tell it and validate it
and check it. I'm on all those levels.
That's where the fundamentals still matter.
You still need to sort of
understand physical principles.
I'm talking about engineering now.
You still need the domain knowledge.
You still need to know what
codes should I be using.
You still need to have a sense of economics,
of team working. So in that sense,
if you want to go into industry,
I still think an engineering, computer
science, maths or physics degree is the right
choice, even though AI
is great at programming
and statistics and data,
you still need to know it.
At this point, I would say
the biggest opportunities
available now are for people who know AI.
So if you look at the job market,
the best-paying jobs today,
the greatest need is for people
who can help the company
to use AI in the best way.
Because AI is not cheap. And so
if you're gonna be spending,
you know, huge amount of money
on tokens and subscriptions,
you wanna extract the most out of it.
So actually at the moment, you need
people who know how to use AI.
That's probably the skill.
And to be fair, this is
actually where younger
graduates are in a better position.
I've spoken to several people and they
have genuinely agreed that I think there
was three scenarios. And this is probably
gonna be a bit negative for older
people, but I'll say it anyway.
So if you were gonna hire an engineer today,
would you hire a 50-year-old
with 30 years of experience,
but who has no AI experience and
actually has some AI negativity?
And I do see that a lot, unfortunately.
Would I hire an AI person that
has no background at all in
engineering? Or would I find
somebody who's sort of early career,
but extremely proficient with
AI and has the right mentality?
It used to be the case that a
lot of companies would want the
extreme expert. And it wouldn't matter if
they know AI because that's somebody what
IT will do or something.
When I spoke to most people, they would
actually prefer option three to one
or two. It's becoming
essential to have those AI skills.
To some, they would rather sacrifice a
little bit of that domain knowledge because
right now what matters more is someone
who can really take advantage of AI.
And I don't mean just take it
and use it and blame it but
be the person who wants to improve it.
In a larger company that's maybe helping
to negotiate which AI tool they should
use, whether they should be building
things internally, understanding all the
different players where
it's good, where it's bad.
So in that sense, if you're
not an expert in AI right now,
at least in today's job market, I would
say you're at a massive disadvantage
and you should learn very quickly.
And by being an expert in AI, I
don't mean just using the chat
interface of ChatGPT. I don't
mean just copy and pasting stuff.
I mean actually getting in and
understanding how it works,
understanding how you could build out some
agents. You can still be using
some of these commercial tools.
I don't mean write it all from
scratch, but somebody who knows how to
do it, knows how MCP servers work, how
to connect different tools together,
has an inquisitive mind, is
looking at where are things going.
That is so valuable. If I
interview somebody now for a job,
I want someone who is passionate about it.
Because like it or not, that
is the technology of today.
It's a bit like hiring
somebody who is, well,
I don't really like to use
computers, 40 years ago.
Yeah, I prefer to do everything by hand.
At that time, maybe
computers were seen as like,
we don't really need it. But for
sure, the company that did have it,
or the same with the internet. If
you hired somebody who was a whiz
with building websites during
the time of the dot com,
that was really valuable for your company.
Having that mindset might have helped you
shift to an online company instead of
just physical stores,
which as many people know,
there's many examples of companies that
failed because they didn't anticipate where
things were going. So that's a
long-winded way of saying that
today I would say it really
matters to know AI itself,
not just background in
engineering or science,
which is still super
important, but AI itself.
And the great thing is now there's so
many YouTube courses, there's so much
free content, many companies are desperate
to give you free training so that you
use their products essentially.
And this is true if you're
working in the software side,
in the area I'm in, in more CAE
and EDA, absolutely massive
opportunities there. So let's look
at what practical skills should
you develop? And maybe we can
look across undergraduate,
postgraduate, and then early
and late stage careers.
If you're an undergraduate, I would
not be tempted to use AI to do
all of the coursework for you.
Even though it's very tempting to do it,
you're sort of ultimately gonna cheat
yourself out of learning some of these
fundamentals that do matter later.
And even I, there's certain things
now I kind of wish that I'd got
even better grounding on
when I was at university.
You know, some of these like fundamental
understanding of mathematical theory or
engineering principles, they
really do give you that intuition
and physical understanding
and logic that helps.
But at the same time, I would
absolutely be using AI as a tutor.
I think I've said this before, I think
AI's greatest role at the moment
is to help you to study. So if
you get a piece of coursework,
instead of sort of copying
and pasting it in and saying,
you know, give me the answer,
essentially, I would do it to like create
me a podcast that will teach me this area.
Or I quite often have it where
I will ask it to create me
a presentation that will teach me the area.
And you can ask it to help
you to do things as long as
it's legally allowed in
whatever study you're doing.
But I would then be like, explain
to me in a high level how
this works and then dive deeper.
It's like having the ultimate tutor.
So in that sense at the undergraduate
level I would use AI as a
teacher not as something that does it
for you or you just you're ultimately
just cheating yourself and you're
not going to learn the things.
In the PhD, wow, if you do
do a PhD or research thing,
if I had AI when I was doing my PhD, my God,
that would have been so
useful, unbelievably useful.
I mean, just incredible productivity.
I just think how much I could have
done, how much more studies I
could have investigated, and the way that
it would have helped me to understand
new areas, just mind blowing.
So I would fully embrace it
as the ultimate companion.
At a sort of research level,
whether it's masters or PhD,
I think the AI should be the bit
where you really hone those skills,
help it to be your own
PhD student a little bit,
to help you to do things. And that's
the mentality that I think most
companies want. They want you
to use AI as your helper,
not just a lazy way that you
just sort of do this for me,
but rather something where you
almost have your own team.
And that's why a lot of companies
are now talking about a sort of
agentic engineer or an AI engineer, and
they don't really mean it to replace
you as an engineer, but it's
almost to give you extra help.
And so you're sat there farming
off things to go and do.
So that's how I would do it.
Now, of course, there's a
debate of what would you
actually study. In that sense, it's very
dependent on your area of study.
But at least if you were doing
it now, then I would still focus
very much on, let's say in engineering,
how can AI work for engineering in
a more holistic way?
That's clearly one topic.
But it doesn't have to be just on AI itself.
If you're coming up with new theories,
or studying fluid mechanics,
AI can just help you to do the
post-processing, it can help you to
understand what's going on.
You don't have to be
studying AI as the topic,
it's just AI can help you essentially.
And I know probably as I'm saying
this, because I've said the word AI
so many times, some people
may be skeptical and think,
but yeah, it would just be unwise
for you not to be looking into
this. The good thing is if you
set that sort of strong basis,
a good strong maths background,
engineering background,
computational science, I would
understand how chips work,
semiconductors work. That's a big area now.
If you think about it, if AI does
become the revolutionary technology,
you need to understand the
methods, how AI works,
how it's trained, how inference works,
and all the stuff around fine-tuning and
agents, etc.—harnesses
and scaffolding, blah,
blah, blah. But arguably what
powers it and what powers
it are chips. So I would argue
that actually learning more about
semiconductors and EDA is
probably a very useful thing.
Learning about, you know, the engineering,
the power, the economics, that whole
stack will be very useful to understand.
But I think you're in a great position
if you have that engineering background,
science background, and you're very
proficient with AI, I think you could turn
to many jobs. But I guess the elephant
in the room is how do you stand out?
If in some ways AI is the great
enabler, how do you make sure
you get the job versus somebody else?
It used to be that you would
just be the best specialist,
the best university, the best degree.
And that is to some extent
still true, but I would argue
that if some of the technical ability is now
taken by AI, then the
soft skills matter even
more. Maybe I, you know,
lean too much into this,
but I cannot tell you how
much I value the soft skills.
I want to see someone who
can work well in a team,
who has the right attitude, who has
the right organisational ability,
who understands emotional
intelligence and sensitivity,
who maybe has skills in languages and
understands different cultures—just
someone who is, you know, good with people.
More and more, anybody who goes
into leadership roles knows this:
how well a company does is really
down to the people and the vibe
and that is a lot about how you
recruit people and the people you
have. The technical ability
matters a huge amount,
but if we argue that AI is gonna
solve some of that technical ability,
the dynamic of the team and the
people is gonna matter more.
So I don't believe you can be
the sort of super brainy but a
bit awkward person that
won't stand out as well.
So I think the sort of soft skills
and I don't mean everyone needs
to be an extrovert, but someone
who can do well in the team is
probably gonna matter even more.
Showing demonstrable proof is important.
I always find that if
someone just sends a CV,
if someone actually shows me a
presentation of something they've built,
something they've done,
something—that's important.
Internships are super important.
That is ultimately the way that
a lot of companies hire now.
They get somebody as an intern, it's
a bit of an extended job interview,
you know, and then they hire.
So actually, because there's so much
open-source stuff out there now,
because AI is so great, you
should be able to build things.
You should be able to demonstrate
your ability much easier than before.
So if you wanna go into a job,
and it's about doing data centre
design, you could probably pick
up some research yourself,
you could build some simulations yourself,
you could do so much just to
prove that you want and are able
to do it, all with relatively
open-source and free tooling.
Now of course the actual
token cost is another thing,
and that's where there's a
lot of student programs,
but frankly, it's probably worth it
for you to pay, and I think most
people do, for a decent
subscription to an AI thing,
because it's gonna help you out.
So, it's hard for me to think,
but if I was starting again,
I think engineering would
still be the right choice.
I would still do it. And I think
it's even more relevant today as
a good degree, regardless
of what you go into,
just because every industry
has been transformed by AI.
And I think engineering gives you
that grounding in those subjects.
Maybe maths, you could
argue, it's very specific.
An engineering degree, by
design, has elements of maths,
elements of physics, elements
of computer science.
I actually think it's a great
all-round degree if I'm being honest.
I mean, I'm biased obviously, but I
think today it's even more relevant for
you. So I've probably not
addressed all of the points, but I
really don't think that this
is gonna be a matter of a mass
wipeout of jobs. Okay, long term if you
extrapolate things and you say robots can
do everything and AI could do everything.
Okay, maybe there's a very
uncertain long term future,
but frankly, none of us know and
it is almost like a sci-fi thing
to look at. I'm not even sure
it's worth looking at that.
I can look at the short to medium
term, years or decades and
I don't see any mass wipeout
of jobs in engineering.
I see just it being a different skill
set, a different sort of productivity.
And that is not something
where people are just gonna
suddenly hire like 50% less.
I just don't see that. I think
you just need to be flexible in
what you will be doing for that company.
At least for engineers, I can't
really comment about all the
other jobs in the job
market, but as engineers,
I can't see a point where we're
gonna suddenly need 50% less
engineers. I think they're
in such short supply.
So I think if you are listening to
this and you are doing engineering
or want to do engineering, I think that's
a very sensible and future-proofed idea.
And, yeah, I probably waffled on
a bit, but I just wanted to give
you some of my perspectives
on this and if you have
questions for me or comments
or thoughts that you have then
please put them in the chat.
I guess YouTube is probably
the easiest place to do it.
All right, I hope you enjoyed that.
The next few episodes will be
back to speaking with a guest,
I think. So, I hope you enjoyed it.
Thanks